hi everyone thank you very much for
joining and the introduction I'll
continue our session on automated
feature engineering broadening the scope
a little bit looking at at more of the
popular frameworks for automated feature
engineering the first please allow me to
introduce myself
I'm Torben working for informal zones
for reading the lovely city of Munster
work for larger clients in the sectors
of banking insurance manufacturing I'd
like to help them also with automation
solutions for the data and what might be
interesting for you in this context is
molasses talk at PI data which was on
automating tuning of the models of the
hyper parameter settings this year is
about feature engineering I'll give an
introduction about feature I'll add a
bit more to the introduction to feature
engineering I'll tell you more about
popular open source tools for automating
this which I'll apply very in a very
applied way you know small case study
alright feature engineering when we
think of a well feature engineering is a
very important task and supervised
learning however when we think of
supervised learning first thing that
comes into mind is a dear machine
learning code that actually if we zoom
out and if we want to deploy a whole
machine learning system there's many
more things we have to do starting with
data collection so I give you the laser
pointer button from left to right the
data collection with to verify the data
clean it then there's feature extraction
extraction which I'll call feature
engineering here this small part is a
machine learning part code and then
there's serving and monitoring of a
model these boxes are meant to be sort
of proportional to the workload that's
required and also maybe to the coding
that's required which is a bit sad
because we just want to do machine
learning and now we have to do much for
programming around that
and even sadder because sixty years ago
we were promised that machine learning
would eliminate the need for detailed
programming effort but luckily to the
rescue comes automated machine learning
or Auto ml which we could define as mmm
eliminating the need for detailed
machine learning effort and well here we
are with Auto male options I'll walk you
from the right to the left
upstream this pipeline for where we are
right now with automation I think with
monitoring I'll give a checkmark at
least for the technical [ __ ] drawing if
you have a model out there see if it's
alive and well think they can be
automated serving infrastructure this is
what DevOps is all about for the machine
learning code itself that's the last
years talk and in other word and other
options other methods until we think
today we're thinking about automation of
feature engineering I'm not mentioning
the first two boxes first because
they're very close to human intuition
and second maybe we need some more
material for next year and today it's
about feature engineering so what's
happening there in practice with feature
engineering starts with an engineer
thinking of explanations if we take for
example this Cagle dataset on the
rossmann challenge we have dates that
come with sales that were achieved on
that day and there's something we want
to predict for the future
usually these sales under five thousands
sometimes they drop to zero then I shoot
a little bit higher and then they
settled that in the five thousands again
so what's happening thinking of
explanations we first look at the base
variables that come with the data set
for example we have weekday is the shop
open is it a state holiday and actually
for that is the shop but open a shop
open seems to be a good feature already
because if it's not open there is no
sales that zero seems to be explained
but what about the next day where the
sales a little bit higher my
explanations would be maybe this because
of a bridge day maybe we people couldn't
go shopping the day before so we might
want to build these variables to make it
easier for the model 2x
this information so we can well derive
these variables from the previous ones
that's feature engineering or in other
words what's happening as there is a
feature matrix in the beginning our
engineer would program some rules that
would extend this feature matrix by new
columns and make it more accessible for
the model so this is the current
practice our feature engineering is
often done manually but unfortunately
right now not all is good I like to plan
out the challenges that we're facing
here the challenges my favorite ones at
least are is very time consuming well
you can't just sit down there as an
engineer and do it you also need the
domain expertise which sort of doubles
the effort you need more people the
experts and when you're done creating
some good features next time you have a
new prediction challenge all you have to
do may be the work all over again
because not transferable to the new data
set against this background of these
challenges I would like to come up with
the small vision also requirements for
what I would like to see of an of a tool
that gives me automated feature
engineering and these are my
requirements I wanna have easy setup
just throw in the data and get back the
features I wanna wanted to be able to
handle time and the data because I want
to one of my features to use the past to
predict the future and not the other way
around
I want my features the generated
features to be self explanatory there
should be simple enough to understand
but maybe sometimes you want to have
complex features of it's adequate you
want to have maybe a high potential
complexity of your features Maria and
then again you don't want to create all
the features that are possible you might
get some noisy features that lead to
overfitting so minimal garbage features
hazard college these are my personal
requirements for automated feature
engineering and I'll come back to them
later checking in with the available
tools that I'll present how this
requirement requirements might be met
and I will look at popular tools in
general tools and we've heard in the
previous talk about maybe someone's
someone's new he
maybe someone clicked in on YouTube so
I'll give given an introduction from my
point of view in general tools for
automated feature engineering do two
things firstly generate features
potentially good features then the
select down the best ones more
specifically what they do they have
certain methods they can apply for
generation popular things to do the
dimensional reduction think of PCA
transformations think of that feature
plus the other one or polynomial
features relational operation if your
data is sitting across different tables
combining them with sequel a sequel like
operations would be would be options for
generating features time series features
your time series has a trend you might
make a feature one might want to make a
feature from that for example
pre-trained embeddings i'll do it more
complicated but it means in general
wouldn't could mean using a pre trained
model too and losing is sort of a
domain-specific pre trained model to
tell you more about the data you see you
see in your features for example give
some text in there and you can use
another domain-specific model to predict
you the meaning of this text as a nice
handy vector you can use that as a
feature or think of transfer learning
and meta learning is a hot topic on
learning what might be good features for
new data set you can learn this over
many data sets find out well in general
for this sort of data that feature
worked and you can predict this with
another model well these are maybe the
most popular ways for future generation
for feature selection fortune is a bit
simpler you could split it in two as
filtering is the univariate or the you
look at individual features feature
candidates and you could for example
correlate them to your target variable
and see if they contain good information
so you want to keep them
there's wrapping well with a
set of all the possible features you
take subsets and use them for your
prediction use in the with the real
model train I'd get a prediction that
prediction has a quality that quality
tells you of that subset was a good one
so you can search for the best subset
that's wrapping that up the wrapping
methods and in this landscape these are
the three tools they're placed like this
the three tools that I would like to
tell you more about and half an hour ago
the previous talk as a side note also
but going more into detail we've got the
details already we learned that auto
feed who could place around here all
right now we can look at these tools bit
more in detail very a very simple way
future tools helps when you have the
data spread across tables say you'll
have customers that place orders for
different products that have a price may
be in a situation where you want to have
good features on your customer from your
diet from the data future tools gives
you so-called primitives of aggregations
and transformations so you can sum up
values you can extract a month from a
date etc and for creating that feature
would combine them would use them in
this way you could start for example
with the price of the products join it
to individual positions of the orders
those positions pull order you can then
sum up and have price per order you know
the customer for that so you get average
again and say that customer you you come
up with a useful feature and say that
customer on average usually spends this
amount of money for an order that's a
useful it's one useful feature
the other thing noteworthy the only next
thing noteworthy for future tools is
that it uses all the available
primitives you give it to make create
all the combinations of features with
the number of steps you allow to take
you so get a lot of features
all right tea is fresh work sometime
serious when you want to extract the
feature from the time series like this
you might take a minimum maximum but it
also gives you as mentioned before
subtle features like the number of Peaks
it has many more implemented very well
documented can you create many features
and conveniently it does not just create
many features for you it also selects
them down with a filtering method
potential features are evaluated
individually their or statistically
tested for interaction with the target
variable ideal on your training ideally
on a training set and then would be
discarded in a very nice convenient way
by the library those that don't have
good interaction with the target
variable this is what she is fresh does
finally teapot takes ingredients from
the scikit-learn api namely
pre-processors selectors and models plus
an extra boost model uses Genetic
Programming for trying to find an
optimal scikit-learn pipeline that
combines these ingredients for going
straight from the input data to making a
prediction well this is the whole
pipeline including the prediction we're
interested in like a feature feature
extraction so one heck that could be
applied here is removing from that
optimal pipeline at least the best
pipeline found removing the model in the
end and then you have a feature
engineering pipeline learn by tpod
alright these three libraries next we
applied in a small and a small case
study those of which were wanted to test
these libraries at their default
settings default settings because we had
automation on a mind there's many
settings you can smelling two settings
you can choose there but let's first
think of well for just you
default or what will happen we also want
to do chief general understanding most
importantly and component comparative
performance also bidding for this we
gave all three libraries the same
machine learning tasks generate features
for time series forecasting and that's
the Rossmann challenge data set as
mentioned before we only use next to
boost model with fixed settings to keep
it a bit simple there I have to mention
one thing is out of scope we're not
finding out here we cannot find out with
this setting which of these librarians
is the best one in general it's about
just understanding what they do and how
they work
alright and before you get the results
I'll tell you a bit more about our
design of experiments so you understand
the results a bit better
the Rossmann dataset then just for one
store was pre-processed just clean some
typecasting simple things then first
feature generation was applied with the
Oh with water or was was that was done
future generation was done with these
three libraries and we had one control
there just manually lagged features a
bunch of lag features Edition 80 is
fresh also 40 fresh features will also
use the build and feature selection all
of these data sets were pass to extra
boost separately for training and also
as the second control we have no
features at all just the base features
just to see how that compares those
separate models are then evaluated for
the performance just to see how good the
features are that were generated I'm a
very aggregated way the very aggregated
way for these for these results of this
evaluation
I'll give you here huh Cooper is missing
well on the x-axis you have the
different methods and yeah you have the
methods the y-axis what you're not
seeing here is the model error
there'll be the RMS II and we have a
sample size of 15 so we're
the random seeds 15 times you get a
distribution of of that performance what
we see is we've seen order of
performance here teapot performed best
which is fresh second future tools
manual was sort of on the same level and
base was less of a first result is
feature engineering features actually
makes sense and helps we're curious
about this convenient filtering method
by T is fresh and maybe you thought
maybe that's an unfair advantage it's
not just generators also selecting
features so we applied this one in
addition to the other feature extractors
you see this in blue here again same
y-axis and you'll have you know you see
different things first thing we see is
that for for feature tools you actually
seen improvement maybe because it was
the was because of the vast amount of
features that were created then
filtering the best ones made sense for
the other two options we didn't see an
improvement actually seemed to hurt the
manual features that were chosen by us
so maybe removing them by coincidence
can I would rather hood teapot didn't
see much of a change and I think this is
because in this might be because
implicitly teapot can learn to select
features in its pipeline and maybe the
good ones were already selected all
right these were the perform other
performance results we are also
interested in what sort of features are
responsible for these before this
performance might learn something there
what we're doing is we're taking the
base features and joining the engineered
features looking at the future
importance of XG boost and see what sort
of good features were found but the base
feature said looks like this we have
open day of week I state holiday a good
features with feature tools a new
variable appears here and that's pretty
much the same as we have here that's
just a weekday feature and surprisingly
they're performing Somali oh well maybe
not surprisingly now
tea is fresh yes to new people if you
are Amanda among the top ones it's quite
a cryptic way here in a fancy way
expressing with an autocorrelation what
day of week it is I think and the second
one I think is a fancy way of saying if
the shop was recently opened or closed
it's a bit cryptic but apparently useful
features teapot also finds the feature
but the way we used teapot it just has
the name too it's not very expressive
but it's there it's useful all right now
with these results I like to come back
to the requirement stage before for
these three libraries very subjectively
oh maybe we've made the following
evaluations was it easy to set up the
tools generally yes just future tools
requires requires you to pass the
relational schema of your data handling
time and the data we didn't see possible
with teapot may be our fault maybe it's
not build in features being self
explanatory
we found this best with feature tools
but teapot we've we've just seen as it
can be quite a black box the high
potential complexity features is mixed
evaluation because I think they all of
them can create quite a complexity but
in the domain of operations they create
that they apply finally the minimum of
garbage features future tools not that's
not that strong there we've seen that
teapot here's a bit better there all
right these are the very zoomed in very
very very very detailed results and just
finally for wrapping it up I just like
to zoom out again and come back to the
question what about this what our
take-home message is here on the
automation potential so first of all
when we started something maybe
noteworthy is
the preparation of the data was still
required especially because we had time
related data making the libraries
understand or temporal constraints there
on engineering features was quite hard
so you could we could actually mess up
there if you do something wrong
full automation we found just using the
default settings of the libraries
definitely seemed possible but it seems
to come at a cost and that's the
potential maybe you would be a little
bit better if you just said done this
there's one or two things differently
especially with feature tools we've seen
that the default settings are quite
limiting and many operations are
excluded excuse me are excluded with the
default settings and yeah might be room
for improvement there and you have to be
aware if you use the default settings
there and finally we might just conclude
that human innovation intervention would
still be beneficial because what we've
done in the steps we've taken the
original base features applied automated
generation and selection and engineering
features there's still some room for us
as humans first is the manual features
that you could for instance generate
before and then feed into the automation
steps and afterwards you might want to
review what what these steps have done
at which point you might want to go back
to the settings of your automatic
generation maybe full selection it might
be handy to have a black and white list
to make sure which features go through
and which ones don't
alright so much about our findings at
gist and this on this final slide I
would like to I don't maybe ask
questions to you and give you some
material first of all the code is open
for reviews and pull request would be
very happy if you'd like to extend it or
change some assumptions they're very
welcome one question we've all we've
brought is can we find better default
parameters for these libraries and maybe
there's some open source libraries for
other methods you would like to include
maybe there's auto feet that should be
included maybe on other methods and may
even maybe even meta-learning and of
course I'm interested for now or during
the break in your opinion on what you
think could be best practice from
combining the manual and the automated
steps of feature engineering anything
you do or you recommend or welcome to
already mention that during the Commons
huh
the questions but feel free ok thank you
very much thank you very much Tom for
the great talk we have time for
questions I think there was one and yes
I'd like to remind you that questions
are preferred over comments hey thank
you very much for the talk I was
wondering I didn't see on your
evaluation criteria something like ease
of use so thinking through those
libraries you know something like
parallelization does it work within a
site get pipeline does it exposed an
inverse transform method do you have an
opinion on which ones were easier to use
than others
I think t-pod is pretty easy to use so
they're very much fits maybe this is the
one that fits the best into into this I
could learn workflow the other ones can
be a bit resource demanding but I found
teapot if you bring the time was was the
easiest to use it was also the reason to
include it's not a classical feature
engineering tool but because it's
popular with the community this is why
we included it so if you want to go easy
maybe teapot further questions hi thank
you for a talk so my question was you
used like default parameters for the
model you tested on in the end you think
it would change like the results a lot
if you use hyper parameter tuning for
those but then and what would benefit
from those most may be um I'm not sure
about the second part but about the
first part of your question I think that
that could change a lot I mean this the
could be Black Swan waiting and changed
all the results so there is a disorder
of performance we really have to take
with a grain of salt
yeah but I think what we've learned
about what's easy to use what the sort
of features look like maybe this is more
generalizable now but again welcome
welcome to it just another script or to
a pipeline and the ripple further
questions I don't see any further
yeah very interesting talk and do you
already have experience with the HTC s a
package a full here with those seven
thousand features so actually actually
we we have not have not used it so far
you mention it in your previous talk
anything you would like to let us know
about this about this library or it's
just library which includes like all the
different possible features which were
found which are over 7000 but there I
would be also interested in like how
does it work when you contracted time I
we should edit if there are no further
question then please give another hand
sorry sorry sorry sorry
alright in your case study TV are pop
performed best also over any cases very
would say okay if you use teapot you're
screwed basically
hmm I think we tried to change to choose
add a dataset or setting of experiment
where none of these libraries had like a
like a natural advantage if we had data
spread across ten tables I mean feature
tools might have had a had a natural
advantage or if you had I'm not sure
we're seeing blue yonder on that batch
there for him but if you use tears fresh
and you you would have an advantage if
you'd have time seems like massive time
series data from
from sensors a lot and then such a
setting you'd have a differential
advantage 40 is fresh so the setting
matters a lot and you ask when teapot
screwed right the way when you would be
screwed if you use cheap out or
something like that well first thing
that comes to my mind is definitely
explain ability yeah you you wouldn't
get this very easily with teapot has
another question come up then please
give another round of applause to talk
[Applause]
[Music]